l'abbé pierre squatteurs parmi les
squatteurs l'avocat les sans abri est
allé en personne avenue rené coty à
paris pour obtenir le retour des
familles expulsées il entend y rester
valérie gage et philippe boisserie et
daniel lefebvre sont sur place
il n'a pas eu peur de braver la foule
malgré ses 81 ans et une santé précaire
il n'a pas eu peur de défier les forces
de l'ordre lui empêchant l'accès de
cette ancienne école où s'étaient
réfugiés des sans-logis son combat de
toujours était encore son combat de ce
jour je ne quitterai pas ce trottoir
tant que ne sera pas respecté la
décision de la cour d'appel et tant que
n'aura pas été ouvert une porte pour que
ces familles entre là où la cour d'appel
leur a donné le droit d'abriter leurs
familles leurs petits enfants je ne
sentirais pas de ce coin de trottoir
jusqu'à ce que cela soit fait
sa détermination que les 17 familles
expulsées fin août est toujours sans
toit puisse faire valoir ce que la cour
d'appel a décidé le 17 septembre un
délai de six mois dans ces lieux pour
trouver enfin une solution
seul problème la ré reconnaît aussi la
légalité de l'expulsion décidée par la
mairie de paris
même si les magistrats rappellent que le
droit au logement est affirmé par la loi
soit votée il ya eu des tests qui ont
retenu le droit au logement sans aucun
doute mais ça ne veut pas dire que
lorsqu'on a un droit on puisse justement
utilisées à des fins des moyens illégaux
pour appliquer ce droit
les juges ont estimé que ces contraint
par la nécessité qu'ils ont occupé les
lieux après des demandes de logement a
dressé pour certains depuis six sept
voire huit ans aux offices hlm leur
message n'a pas forcément été entendu la
voix chancelante de l'abbé pierre aura
peut-être plus de porter auprès de jean
tiberi arrivé sur place il y à quelques
instants